it's lit terribly it's poorly lit hi
guys my name is grace hell baby don't
know now you know your life is different
now I am in London England
I am tired overwhelmed yep got it all
together
matron I flew in on a red-eye this
morning then I fell asleep for a few
hours and I don't know what time it is
12:30 at night so the perfect time to be
starting my video for today if you don't
know why I'm in London one in which is a
bunka the bunka 'aa Ward's it's an award
show Volquez is memory now representing
an awards are tomorrow night and then
after that we were performing this might
get weird y'all here in London and in
Dublin so if you haven't bought your
tickets yet for the show please do
there's links in the description below
we've been working on it all night and
yes we did a photo shop with dicks
bicycle and yes it will be in the show
so that's a major spoiler the American
Music Awards the AMAs happened over the
weekend I'm 12 layers of scum deep let's
review some red carpet fashion should be
all right we're doing it together except
you're watching me do it by myself
Eddie gaga Joanne look at this okay look
at this Dick Tracy because it's look at
this [ __ ] Tracy I like this a lot she
looks like a mobsters wife that could
like break your dick off with her thighs
cute Selena Gomez this is beautiful this
kind of looks like when a bride tells
her bridesmaids you can pick out
whatever kind of dress you want just go
with the red color scheme and then one
of the bridesmaids shows up like this
and she's like what the Jeana you're
wearing a wedding dress but in red am i
this is kind of Selena Gomez's comeback
I guess and I guess she gave a speech
that made people cry that's always a
wonderful human quality to feel in
yourself the ability to make others cry
how powerful Chrissy Teigen damn girl
no one's talking about side boob it's
all side but 2016 you're the side but
this is the mom is what moms with I this
is a mom damge mom I do feel nervous for
your vagina your vagina is just hanging
in the balance of these chic car wash
panels that you're hoping stay in place
all night cute are gonna Grande haven't
you worn this before isn't this a thing
doing this to the VA
right you have a very distinct look
businessman pants on the bottom cocktail
waitress top up top altogether the
entire staff of a casino olivia munn I
just went into a new house so my kitchen
could use some new dinnerware can you
tell me where you got such a gorgeous
chest plate good night
quiche Karlie Kloss I feel like this is
like a movie in which your time machine
shop and so like your teenage self I was
going to your 80s prom got hybrid with
like your sophisticated adult model self
you gotta get that machine fixed janelle
monae oh I love everything janelle monae
wears and this looks amazing you look
like the fakest employee that footlocker
has ever had Haley Steen first time for
your Seinfeld Seinfeld steam Feldstein
felt Steinfeld Stern filled Stern
stained fields it's a family name wow
this is very great gasps he meets Oh
buddy you look like the beautiful sexy
magician's assistant that's just had
enough and your face is like he thinks
he's gonna open up that box and I'm
gonna be in there mmm Heidi Klum is
there this is my favorite thing about
award shows it's just like how long
until Heidi Klum touches down Wow Wow
you are a gift okay wow this is mm-hmm
why not you kind of look like um like a
folder that I used to put in my binders
in high school you also look like a big
ol roll of washi tape cute
suhara is there and pregnant and Wow up
top it looks like you're going to a
poetry reading in the bottom it looks
like your duvet cover got stuck in your
panties on the way out the door
cute cozy huh whoa this is very Britney
Spears oops I did it again but like not
that I feel like this is 11 from
stranger things just going through her
like acting out late teenage years
xa doorbells garage EP Henson Wow Wow
and with your eyebrows and face are just
like slapping me because they're so
strong and fierce just out I get it you
can buy like an oversized ill-fitting
button-down shirt from like Costco
and look amazing I get it Bing ah why am
I so attracted this thing that's a
good-looking man
they were shape-ups okay you look great
goddamn goddamn Niall Horan from One
Direction previously now of his own
volition
you look cute you look like a dish towel
that I got from Ikea that's in my
kitchen right now cute very domestic
Shawn Mendes why do you always look like
a hot dad as a teenager and it's such a
conflicting look why do you make me feel
so many things who gave you the right to
be a teen DILF god damn it that's cute
bella thorne who did this to you gigi
hadid
looks like she just sucked a dick i
don't mean that in a that's i don't you
your mouth I didn't say that you did it
just your mouth is good my camera
literally shut off so that's good that
it didn't clearly want me to continue
with that thought thanks camera this is
a really cute boy Lee but I have to say
Gigi um my mom and I did this look for
you sorry
idina menzel has seen something awful
this is the face of someone that's
watching the apocalypse approached
someone who still hasn't totally
processed Trump's presidency or someone
that is currently ship it's good for you
Gigi gorgeous get that out of my face
you look incredible oh my god I don't
even care that someone stole the top
half of your dress and your sleeves you
look good girl okay well there's my
brief overview of the AMAs red carpet
fashions what did you guys think I know
I probably missed a lot of people that
you really enjoyed on the red carpet let
me know and if you like this video give
it a thumbs up hit this button right
here subscribe to my youtube channel why
not and if you haven't bought your
tickets to that this might get where
y'all shows in London and Dublin please
click the link in the description box
below that's it I don't know good I
don't just I don't know anymore anymore
it's on all the known all the know is
gone